game we got a low ticket Alert in
Cleveland and Columbus so if you want to
catch the show you better make a move
baby yeah gang there's a handful of
tickets left at each show and then
obviously the second show added at the
Vogel theater in Red Bank New Jersey
August 11th that's more than halfway
sold out get those tickets let's sell it
out gang we'll see you out there peace
peace welcome to another exciting
edition of are you garbage
show where you find out if your favorite
comedians are classy individuals or
absolute trash now here are your hosts
Kevin Ryan and H Foley
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's new favorite podcast this
is are you garbage oh yeah it's a little
show we sit there with your favorite
comedians and we find it at the group to
be classy or if they're just a big old
piece of trash I'm your host Dave
trolley coming at you on a beautiful day
we're out back here at hoodies in the
new edition she's up on the roof with a
new set of binoculars okay trying to get
a look at that new widower that moved
into the house next door taking a little
peek at him great okay my co-host is
coming at you from right next to me he
is the CEO of Ru garbage he's an
international businessman and he's my
best pal in the whole wide world and I
love him give it up for KJ Kevin James
Ryan what's swinging a Miss on the teddy
joke what's up everybody thanks for
tuning in as always please make sure you
rate you subscribe on iTunes full video
available on YouTube as you know those
numbers are cooking then obviously the
greatest website of all time
www.patreon.com gang check it out it's a
party over there yes it is and having a
nice quick shout out to our producer
extraordinaire the magic man makes us
all look good works the ones the twos
the threes and the fours give it up for
T-Bone mcsprax it's Toby McMullen
everybody hey buddy what up dudes a
beautiful day out here we got a legend
in the Edition
ain't lying a pro baby
gang a long hair ain't line we couldn't
be more excited to have our incredibly
and I mean incredibly special guest here
with us today for the first time he's a
very funny very successful stand-up
comedian actor and television
personality and you may have seen him in
but not limited to here we go we got
Sullivan and Son we got the detour
Better Call Saul the last OG space force
the opening act only murders in the
building hell of a week with Charlemagne
the God the 2022 sleeper hit confessed
Fletch with Jon Hamm we got American Dad
Star Search premium blend The Late Show
with David Letterman death Comedy Jam
Last Comic Standing Conan last call this
week at the Comedy Cellar this is not
happening The Tonight Show The View
Wendy Williams Colbert Seth Meyers Kelly
Clarkson Colbert WTF The Joe Rogan
Experience he has multiple stand-up
specials including 2017's Father Figure
2019's no one loves you
2021's imperfect messenger and he just
hosted the 2023 correspondence dinner he
is on tour right now and for the last
several years he has been your favorite
correspondent on The Daily Show but the
big question about his mind today is he
garbage I'll tell you this the guy wears
a suit like nobody's business
for Roy Wood Jr everybody
[Applause]
what is the budget for me
for Red Bull and cocaine
on this program it's true to roof I'll
tell you that much you [__]
didn't take a breath
I'm Amazed
no stumbles no fumbles just straight
professionalism into that microphone the
show's brought to you by the cineola
cartel yeah shout out to the boys down
here happy to be here [__]
thank you for having me
oh man we've been looking forward to
this man this is good this is good happy
to have you you know it's gonna be a
good podcast when there's a beer cooler
it's decoration
that works
for Dustin decorations and they're ice
cold baby you want a pop we'll give you
a pop Roy he's got decoration beer I
gotta take a picture
[Laughter]
um before we get into your backstory I
just had a question for you just hosted
the correspondent dinner yeah uh what
was the grub like what was the food like
it was it was okay but you gotta even
remember I'm I have to perform sure and
they bring you it's the work you know
what sucks about the correspondence
dinner is that it's the only comedy show
where you're just sitting on display for
the audience that sucks for two hours
there's there's 30 minutes and then
there's like an hour of food
and then there's the actual proper
programs that people see on television
what you see on TV we're already 90
minutes into the [__] yeah you should be
in a green room yeah you should be
somewhere sit there on display like
meatballs [__] medieval days yeah you
[__] joke boy yeah sit there and make
small talk with the Madam first lady
y'all ain't got [__] in common oh
YouTuber eats what's going on trying to
find Common Ground yeah it's it's
literally you guys watching beef huh
what's the deal imagine small talk with
a person whose life you couldn't imagine
yeah
and I'm sure she had the same thought on
her side what the [__] am I gonna talk
to this black dude from Alabama about
for two [__] hours you don't take a
helicopter to the grocery store yeah no
but so that part of his is weird right
it's just just people looking at you and
going
I hear about like you're a fighter pop
oh you're gonna get him yeah literally
like you that's really what it is it's
like you're taxiing out for war
like Tom Cruise when he gets the ghost
signed to the dude on the carrier Deck
with a prime rib and a crab cake in
front of you for the Catapult launches
you off to the podium they're waiting
like poor bastard ain't coming back yeah
so it's it's uh it's it's it's it's a
psychotic thing but I'm sure I would do
it again yeah really I would do it again
I was juggling Dynamite it's sure yeah
yeah like what you really think is a
stand-up community median how many
performances as a stand-up still truly
matter
or still get some level of eyeballs on a
regular basis and that's one of them
sure on the level of like say what a
Tonight Show credit for sure pre-leno
I'm talking Carson you'd rip on Leno
even Leno and Letterman you'd rip in the
90s and [__] would be off to the
side of the stage and go here's your
career congratulations yeah where this
still has that level of gravity yeah
that's why I give you got to give props
to Chris Rock for doing a live live
special yeah sure I went back and dug in
the crates and was just looking at some
of the people who did it before
and nobody really remembers this and
it's not talked about but [__] Sinbad
he did it Sinbad hang on I'm gonna blow
your [__] wide open
Sinbad did a live Prime Time comedy
special
squeaky clean
with commercial breaks what damn now a
few words from our sponsors can't get to
try them oh the [__] that's nuts do you
time your jokes right to the commercial
break yeah cause you got to have someone
someone's got to be like five four three
and you're performing during the
commercial break [__] and will become
back from commercial you've got to merge
perfectly back with the TV audience at
home damn so you essentially have on air
and off air material that has to be
timed perfectly for what
that's nuts
that's juggling Dynamite yeah yeah he
hosted my Gotham Comedy live in like
2009 or whatever and that [__]
killed him he was dude he was hosting he
was doing door he was doing [__] during
the commercial breaks that was one of
the greatest he is on my Mount Rushmore
I don't even know we got this place but
that dude is just [__] yeah there's
the famous story about him I don't know
where it was it was Montreal or
something like that everybody bombed and
he had went and got a pair of socks that
day and didn't really have anything
prepared and went out there and just
murdered about buying socks I think
that's a norm McDonald's or they were
talking about it in the Green Room it
was Norm was like 19 and they were
talking about socks and then he goes
down I was like hey just went out and
[__] talked about socks and like
murdered I got like a television deal
and everything I thought you're going to
tell the snow plow story
he's doing a show at a casino during the
snowstorm
does an hour as he's getting ready to
rap like going into his last bit a
single couple walks in and shuffles into
their seat and he goes where the [__]
have you all been and they go we were
stuck behind a snow plow on the you know
on the Hills we just couldn't go around
a snowplow
so we're just now getting here he goes
all right cool
does his closer then tells the audience
that's it for you all you're welcome to
leave if you want but I'm gonna do
another hour for these two people man
that's Pro [__] man and he did another
goddamn different hour yeah a whole
different [__] hour of course no one
left uh-huh he does another power as a
treat to two people who were stuck
behind a snow plow man that's how you
become
who the [__] you know with an extra hour
in their back pocket I don't have an
extra 10 minutes what are we talking
about here bro
so you know you have to do things and
stand up that I think still halfway keep
the craft relevant sure yeah that does
for sure yeah that's one of those things
where it's like even if you don't watch
it live
like I didn't want to live but I go
watch everybody finds out about the
comics yeah set yeah yeah yeah so it's
still it still is still relevant so you
know yeah I'd do it again and even if I
bomb I can still say a little kid I got
him the first time
[Laughter]
I saw you right before you did it you
were running spots you were running
running in the West Village you remember
it was like a couple weeks ago when I
saw you you had your your notes in your
hand and you were walking down I was
like hey what's going on I was trying to
get this stuff ready to go yeah I yeah
we had a couple writers and they're like
oh we're coming no
I know whether or not it's gonna work
I'll send you audio of what sucks that
was the part that was
frustrating it's like the news kept
changing sure so for all this
preparation you're doing
oh yeah sorry about that the Don Lemon
just got fired so yeah scratch that page
so drop the Spy balloon joke to make
your own for Don Lemon okay cool oh yeah
Tucker Carlson
got fired so though the the Mike Pence
and the Nikki Haley stuff yeah don't do
oh keep it fresh sorry the fox Dominion
lawsuit just yeah got settled that was a
wacky couple of weeks everything was
dropping oh man so you know most of what
half of that set was I mean we cooked
fresh that week damn because the news
broke that week yeah I felt like an easy
choice I feel like an idiot after I saw
you because you were like I'm just
trying to get these jokes ready and you
were like very focused and I was like oh
you're gonna do great don't worry
you got Moxie kid but you're going down
the car I was like what the [__] is
wrong with it so to answer your question
I couldn't taste the food
because I was so [__] nervous but it
looked good like I ate the salad the
salad part I must have something so I
don't collapse but it looked good oh man
it's funny um give us the back story on
Roy Wood Jr where'd you grow up give us
give us a scoop there's not much to say
bro I grew up in Alabama okay
well we moved there when I was in the
third grade we moved there from Memphis
okay and so
just I was I was like a basic like I
wasn't a Class Clown okay like a regular
kid yeah I was a regular kid I didn't
really start wild until College like I
played baseball and well I rode the
bench in high school high school
um what's your mom and dad do uh my pops
is a was a journalist uh radio
journalist but okay I covered like black
issues or whatever but like black
conflict I should say so he was embedded
in pretty much any black conflict you
can name from the 50s to
Ellie riots damn
so wait till South African rides the
Rhodesian Zimbabwe Civil War he was like
in the [__] oh getting shot at all that
the whole [__] Vietnam with you know
predominantly black platoons he would go
over he was he was like volunteer no
[__] send me where black people are
dealing with [__] no [__] and I will
take a tape recorder damn you want a gun
nope for real give me a tape recorder
and we'll go follow those stories come
home cover the Civil Rights Movement
you know pretty much that was that was
his thing you know my dad was you know
real big on black righteousness my mom
you know she marched you know a lot but
you know she settled on you know higher
education she's been in higher education
almost 40 years now okay like that's her
Lane like her Lane is just educating and
bettering people my pops died when I was
16. so I started working a lot more and
that's kind of where like you start
getting that hustle mentality because
you don't want to be a burden on your
parents like your mom like my my pops
dies we lose half the income in the
house sure so my mom is struggling just
to keep the house while I get ready to
graduate from high school so I'm working
every side job you can name
um what was that like landscaping or
like groceries yeah what was the first
job first the first with the pay stub
was Baskin Robbins shout out to it 31
Flavors Western Hills Mall
Baskin Robbins in the mall dude I had a
mall job at 15 and the girls who used to
work at simply six or three five seven I
would give them extra ice cream of
course that was my way of flirting yeah
but I wouldn't give it on the top
because my manager was looking so I
would like pack the inside of the cone
it's a three pound cone yeah
the most dense ice cream was for you
baby
two hands baby a couple 20 stuffed in a
sugar cone bro I I just I just worked I
worked I I raked leaves I'd flip my
Nintendo tapes I would sell that [__] I
would sweep I would sweep parking lots
at um at gas stations in the hood
because
the guys that worked in the Hood the
guys who worked at the gas station in
the hood they have to go out and sweep
the parking lot like once or twice a
week or whatever and they hated doing it
because you're constantly going in and
back and forth customers
so I go to the guy one day and this is I
wasn't I got sent to summer school in
the ninth grade for algebra and the seat
I had in the classroom I could just
[__] see the gas station and I just
[__] watched this guy every [__]
day just going back and forth and just
every day and he would come out around
like one o'clock and so one day I go to
him I go hey man
I know you can't pay me
but just give me ten dollars worth of
candy
write it off as shoplifting Jesus
and I'll sweep this [__] for you every
day
and so he goes you got a deal
so after summer school I will go over
there I will sweep the parking lot who's
doing [__] write-off schemes that
[__] night I just fell in algebra but
you're [__] yeah how'd you do an
algebra that summer well I'd walk in
it's like uh you remember that scene in
Casino where they're showing the guy
going to count room and he just walks
out with money yeah yeah he's skimming
the skin and they're skimming the skin
and nobody sees anything
all right boys all these kids are in
line to pay for their candy and [__] and
I'm just walking out with a [__] 48
counselor
bars we had Skittles the whole nine
yards nobody said nothing and then it
was Jimmy two times I'm going to get The
Laffy Taffy Let's Get The Laffy taffies
ah shout out to a laffy taffy so I take
ten dollars worth of candy flipper to
school for 20. damn what the [__] so now
that's 20 raw profit in my pocket for a
job
he's talking
right off shortage raw profit yeah
Eddie's in summer school no overhead
other than other than the 30 minutes it
takes to sweep sure to sweep the [__]
out pay off a couple of cops and keep it
moving
detective Jenkins plays ball yeah so
that was
that was that was that was my childhood
man was just figuring out ways to make a
little bit of money I was we grew up it
was a bad neighborhood apartment house
what were you guys in we're in a house
we're in a house on the west side of
Birmingham neighborhood called West End
and so we're at South Park Road
essentially Pearson Avenue this would
have been late 80s early 90s Birmingham
84. so this is the rise of crack the
beginning of white flight I had one
white neighbor
there was at the time there was still a
white biker gang they were like the last
holdouts of in the neighborhood yeah and
they would
God bless them because they they tried
to hold down
that was their Alamo literally yeah yeah
literally and they just like they would
ride their bikes through the hood and
[__] and then like this is the rise uh
you know late 80s is the rise of
speakers subwoofers sure so dudes is
coming down the block
and they will pull up next to the like
the gas station was next to the biker
Club clubhouse or whatever so it's just
a battle of just
Rob Base cranking legit rock bass at
that point we was it was Miami base it
was a lot of Luke there was a lot of two
Live Crew that made it with Uncle Luke
Birmingham so we grew up in a pretty
there was there was there was a lot of
[__] going on in the neighborhood okay
my mom did a good job you know she kept
me busy a lot of after school a lot of a
lot of boys club
a lot of going to the library like any
time I was in the hood I was always on
the way somewhere and so then the thing
that really turned attack
she bought me a basketball goal
when I was in Middle School for the
house yeah because I would go up to
powderly Park and shoot and
I never had problems I saw problems but
I never had problems like people never
really bothered me per se but my mom
goes now if I could I want you close to
the house so she buys a gold
Plexiglas backboard nice adjustable oh
no no no that would have been yeah now
that would have been crazy that was the
height of technology in the 90s forget
it get the broomstick or whatever
so because we had the only we only we
had the only house with a driveway that
was in the shade during the day
so you can play shaded basketball and we
also learned a few houses
in the neighborhood the way it was
configurated with a two-car garage
you could play almost half court if you
play off into the grass so gotcha so
half court in the shade in the middle of
the day in the summer
popular spot I would imagine crib became
powderly part yeah and so because of who
my father was and my father was a known
name on the radio I had a brother at the
time who was a who was a prime time
anchor for the NBC affiliate geez no
kidding our family name within the city
of Birmingham at least in the black
community sure pretty solid so it's a
lot of people who I know
I know you I know you run and do a lot
of dangerous [__] but when they were at
our house there's some respect rules
yeah that's pretty cool and they
respected my mom because my mom taught
half of them I taught the older brothers
sure so
there was a bad element it's a bad
neighborhood but that house there was
never anything a little bit Sanctuary to
a house never got broken into no
graffiti no [__] no drama like not a
[__] thing so that when I got to high
school and I started going to summer
school because I didn't go to my zone
high school so
when you go to summer school in those
days in Birmingham you go to your Zone
school for summer school which means I
was around a bunch of kids in theory
that I shouldn't know okay but I know
all of y'all because all y'all come to
the house playing basketball yeah so it
gave me the freedom to move through a
bad neighborhood with a degree of
Diplomatic Security that's pretty good
because if you [__] with me you can't
come shoot yeah
so that's kind of all right man that's a
cool story so that that's just you know
you can call it luck you can glad
whoever the [__] planted them trees did
back in the 30s
let's talk about base baby if you're
anything like me when you travel you
want to be prepared as possible for any
situation that's the Kippy rule baby
base luggage is here to help you bring
as many changes of emergency underwear
as you want as a guy who shorts himself
let me tell you an extra pair of drawers
ain't too shabby created by on-the-go
actress Shea Mitchell base luggage is
made for functionality by a woman who
knows a thing or two about travel baby
they sent us the duffel bag it's
fantastic it's got a little area for
your shoes you beep up and Scat all over
the place I'm changing shoes two three
times a day just because I can the bags
truly have it all 360 degree gliding
Wheels a cushion handle a built-in
weight indicator washable bags for dirty
clothes and tons of interior pockets for
all Essentials in case you've all in
case
you're already worried about messing up
your Brand New Bag base was created to
look even better with miles so go ahead
Chuck it in the overhead bin get a
little rough with it you know what I
mean right now bass is offering our
listeners 15 off your purchase off your
first purchase by visiting
basetravel.com garbage go to base travel
b-e-i-s travel.com garbage for 15 off
your first purchase that's base travel
b-e-i-s travel.com garbage do it ladder
ladder ladder baby in life you can put
off a lot of things doctors appointments
going to the DMV doing the laundry but
one thing you can't put off is getting
life insurance baby don't jam up to
people when you're gone one last final
screw job as I like to say time to cross
uh things off your to-do list and why
don't you start with life insurance
through ladder it's 100 digital no
doctors no needles no paperwork when you
apply for three million in coverage or
less all you need is a phone or laptop
to apply you find out if you're
instantly approved and you get a full
refund if you change your mind in the
first 30 days it's easy peasy I went on
figured it all out got approved now Hans
ain't gonna get screwed when I croak you
know what I mean there's no hidden fees
it's no wonder why they made Forbes best
life insurance list for 2021
so go to latterlife.com garbage a day to
see if you're instantly approved that's
ladder life
l-a-d-d-e-r-life.com garbage
latterlife.com garbage do it gang check
it out take care of it don't screw over
your family set them up real nice but
yeah but that was it man I [__] went
to college I started doing stand-up in
college I stole some credit cards in
college now we're talking hold on a
second
[Laughter]
it wasn't a scam it was simple let's say
it was 92 for legal purposes
what do you mean this [__] can be
Googled I don't know if you need to be
Google you have to go down to the
courthouse and like request or Freedom
of Information
the Patriot Act on Roy wood yeah so I
was a mail soldier in the post office
and back in those days credit cards came
out there was no calling and credit
cards yeah there was like this idea of
calling a number and hello it's me turn
my credit card on please
[Applause]
every credit card in Alabama keeps
getting stolen the Roy Wood Junior law
so so I take some cards we go down to a
department store we buy some [__] the
girl knew it the girl knew what was that
sure so she under charges us
in order to leave more space on the card
so we can buy more [__] damn
to which after effect I'm going well why
the [__] did you do that when I could
have just
started
didn't need you to be courteous and
leave more space on the car and that's
how we got caught because you can't buy
Tommy Hill figure for eight dollars sure
ah so if you're working like let's say
let's say you're working and this is
right at the turn of the technology and
department store loss prevention where
your manager security could be watching
your register and get a same time image
of what you're ringing up to make sure
you're not [__] around and skipping
yeah
I worked at Macy's I know okay so you
know so they're making sure that you're
not skip scanning but in the process of
checking her for skip scanning they're
going
why the [__] did she just charge him
eight dollars for a Tommy girl yeah yeah
that's not the right price yeah [__] so
that's what happened so I get probation
well at the time I thought I was going I
was told I was going to prison so
I'm like well my lawyer said I'm going
to prison I always wanted to do comedy
like that Sinbad fella I saw in
Primetime [__] it here's a chance to try
it before my life completely implodes
started doing comedy got probation been
doing comedy ever since there you go
kid's a worker graduated got my degree
in journalism Dean's List the rest of
the way really my mom and I
it's wild because
you know going back to the
correspondence dinner thing like
you know you got two parents that's on
that fought for every possible chance
for you to be successful as a black
person and blah blah blah blah
and then you get ground up in the system
so when I get probation I get back in
school my mom's like good and I graduate
and I'm going
yeah I think I need to go and uh do some
stand-up comedy yeah of course he was
thrilled I'm not gonna be doing no
internships or any of this
extracurricular journalism [__] um
to be honest I'm gonna just graduate
because I think it's part of my
probation turn the good grades is one of
my terms so I got you the Tommy Hilfiger
for Christmas Mom yeah what's the
problem yeah put on your Tommy jacket
shut the [__] up
so
so my mom and I those are awesome by the
way yeah yeah we don't we don't talk we
talk literally once a month for a year
and it's a five minute conversation to
ensure that the other person is alive
Okay so
she's not with comedy I need to hold it
no no no they're good so
I start riding the bus to do open mics
and [__] because I'm in Tallahassee I'm
in Florida a m and so in in the south in
the 90s Open Mic was not a weekly thing
in most markets Atlanta had a weekly
open mic
Tampa Bay had an open mic shout out to
coconuts and St Pete Beach yeah it's
still there yeah still standing so
I could go there weekly but if you
wanted to do more you had to bounce
around and so I would go whatever I
could I would Google comedy clubs yeah
and so I would go to Birmingham once a
month to do open mic and that was Where
I Stood that was the first Club I did
was Birmingham and so
just on a whim like eight nine months
into the [__]
I go to Birmingham to do the open mic
I'm sleeping at the bus station because
I don't want my mom to know Jesus what
the [__] I'm doing so I would get to the
bus station go out to Hoover do the show
go back to the bus station and sleep
until the bus one of my mom's [__]
students saw me
goes back to the campus and snitches on
me so that's how my mom found out what
was going on she's Furious and I'm like
I'm not gonna stop I don't know what the
[__] to tell you but my grades are solid
and the deal we made was give the grades
good if my grades are good you can't say
[__] about anything else I do in life
and you made that deal and you agreed to
that and I'm upholding my end of the bar
and I wouldn't [__] my mom a concession
Dean's List week later
dropped out of college
2000 2001 Ford Focus
for Christmas as a gift
so I can stop sleeping in the bus
station she still did not agree with it
she never talked down great lady she
never talked down on what I did but she
definitely always wanted me to be safe
she would put my safety above and
everything good mother I had to catch
the payments but she made the down
payment because she knew and what the
car did the car opened up the whole
[__] Eastern seed sure so I can
still get back to class no bus schedule
no this no that I put my classes Tuesday
through Tuesday through Thursday
Thursday night I'm [__] gone bro I'm
going for five days just sleeping on
couches sleeping in the car now but at
but like Flying J truck stops and all
that so it's wild to go from that moment
to the correspondence of course
and I'm able to give my mom a shout out
because she's in the [__] audience oh
damn wow which is just a you know I
don't know it's amazing yeah for the
course it's [__] crazy dude you know
how many people don't make it that sleep
at bus stops every other person but you
every single guy who's ever slept in a
bus there's like three that made it I
like how she slipped the payments on you
yeah
here's a liability for the next three
years but that crime [__] is weird man
because it was wild as that and I don't
know if it's like this in every city but
like in Tallahassee
Tallahassee is the type of City at least
it was at that time where it doesn't
matter what dirt you do you meet
everyone that's doing dirt sure because
if I'm if I'm if I'm taking credit cards
out of the post office and I'm [__]
buying jeans and clothes then I start
taking this [__] and selling it well now
you're selling stolen goods to people
who yeah yeah you're not selling Goods
stolen goods to people like your mom
you're selling Goods people that are in
the in the market for stolen Gym Boys
yeah so when you get arrested
the the first thing the police try to do
is pin
every [__] crime that's ever been
committed in the [__] City since the
history of crime on you or prove your
connection to others to other people and
so before the end until before they even
like took me in the process and they got
they got me an interrogation and they're
like all right we got you on the jeans
but do you know of these other crimes
and then like telling me this like check
chiting and [__] cocaine and [__]
this
apparently there's like a sex house in
Tallahassee
and they're just showing me picture
after picture after picture of people
and I [__] know every single time
it was a murder last week and the guy
was wearing CK one what do you know
about it literally literally [__] like
that and they're going do you know
anything we have an investigation about
this do you know this guy and I'm like
trying to keep my eyebrows still because
in my head I'm like that [__]
I thought he just was the weed man it's
like just stay still eyebrow stay still
so that's when you realize
but when you walk back through the
scenarios right and it's like [__] I was
at that motherfucker's house last week
yeah it's crazy if they pull a kick
though and I'm in the house you're
wrapped up with it and then it's group
possession just if you're in the room
with dope it's your dope
especially in Florida yeah yeah I come
in a room with you and there's a gun
like it's like stuff that I knew you
were kind of
a Shifty person because I'm being Shifty
but you're seven like keep in mind all
this is 18 I'm 19 years old you're not
doing character value judgments on
people yeah you're rooted you're rooted
in good morals and you're like I assume
these people are they're I'm here to
silly jeans yeah I am not robbing people
no one's going to therapy over this
because of a credit card that you but
that's my thought process like it's a
victimless crime like like there isn't a
direct trauma being in like that's my
brain but I'm dealing with people that
were like really [__] deep off in off
the reservation yeah wild [__] bro and
I'm like oh I really got lucky yeah not
for sure
so you know I live a life that could
have gone
the other way very easily right down to
the judge who decided to give me
probation who wasn't even the regular
[__] judge that does the sentencing
damn could have got the regular
[__] been done so you know I
look at my life Michael the old school
year in trouble bro my whole life is
just a [__] straight up second chance
so all I say is trying to be decent in
my [__] and try and Elevate people I
had the probation show for Comedy
Central where I essentially
played my probation officer
you know did the pilot didn't go or
whatever but like that was a show that
was based on what the system would look
like if it was built with people who
actually give a [__] about the because
there's way more people on papers than
in prison
yeah we talk about all this prison
reform [__] half the people that's
caught up in the revolving door is
because they're on probation or parole
or from something you got a [__] ass po
or you had a [__] ass lawyer or a [__]
ass judge you just had one person in
your process that didn't give a [__]
about you and you're in jail or you go
back to jail so like I know my life
could have been that so you know with
what I've been given I try to be decent
try to help [__] fantastic try
to get good wholesome I try not to be
garbage
we'll we'll get there
uh-huh okay speaking of which yeah
um but did you guys do any vacations
when you were a kid where would you go
it was a family vacay like not many I'm
the ninth of 11 kids holy [__] how did
we miss that I'm my mom's only so
there's that okay pop said to [__]
make his Nick Cannon round
when he wasn't at War yeah embedded and
telling the black people yeah three
Vietnamese brothers and sisters
we gotta fix the silver rice hey baby
come meet me after the protest
what you doing after the protest young
lady come on
um were you were you close with all of
them
the closest in age the rest of them
we're cool but it's just everybody's all
doing their thing when you're 10 years
old with a 30 year old brother what the
[__] yeah that's what my family is yeah
we're great now because we're men and
we're grown but at that age it wasn't
the same but the few road trips I do
remember most of them were when I still
lived in Memphis and my my mom and I
were commuting to Birmingham because my
dad had taken a job in Birmingham but
didn't want us to move with him yet
until you know make sure it's stable
yeah
and then we would take road trips up to
Chicago
where my father is from and we would
listen to eight tracks my dad had a CB
radio nice nice and like that was my
first
like
prank calls talking [__] to the trucker
turkey boy that was the best as a kid
man yeah yeah and them truck is they get
mad yeah we did it we did it once on the
Jersey Turnpike and the guy was like I
see you in the red Subaru and we're
gonna kick the [__] out
freaking out man
no CB radios were all right yeah that
was like OG social media man like that
was that I remember that the most is
just being in the car what kind of car
were they whipping around in my pops had
a Lincoln Mark Seven okay he was he
collected Lincoln's well not collected
but like he'd flip him every two years
Lincoln or he go Mark eight he go
Continental
um we got the old box uh Lincoln Town
Car
with the corners yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah the ones that were delivery cabs
for a while yeah here in New York yeah
yeah every once in a while you get to
call an Uber if you're in the boroughs
you get one of them and that back seat
is about 15 feet long you're in there
just chilling in the back of that thing
a little faint smell of smoke in there
yeah but we would you know we would go
on road trips here and there but nothing
major nothing nothing major like my dad
did me in a way that
it's kind of similar and this is what
I'm trying to avoid with my son like my
dad when he would get speaking engaged
so you know when he kind of retired from
like War reporting and all of that and
was just doing news commentary on the
radio he gave up for speaking engagement
and [__] like that no different than say
like a Tavis Smiley or I don't want to
say Al Sharpton but the same gigs they
work the same circuit he's got Sharpton
and career Arc but
so if my dad got booked somewhere fun
he would take me with him that's cool
and then pass me off to some younger
journalist or person or whoever's there
like he got we took a private flight
damn Epcot my props got flown private to
Epcot to Disney and it was just some
woman I to this day I can't remember her
name but just some lady her job all day
which is watch you take my boy to the
rides [__]
and like that's what we did
I remember 93
um
I I rode I flew with my father to
Houston for the National Association of
black journalists he was getting a
Lifetime Achievement Award there you go
and I just remember some random person
just take my boy across the street to
the Astrodome so you can see this and
see some [__] and I just went and did a
tour of the astronaut that's awesome and
I don't even think it was some official
tour I just think it's about pops
knowing people yeah in the city let them
walk around type thing yo my dad helped
and hired so many journalists that are
still indebted to him that he literally
could just pull up in town [__] a
babysitter
hey you didn't I give you a job in 70.
watch my boy
bro when I used to come to Birmingham in
the summer
now this is the most ridiculous [__]
the school year in Memphis ended three
weeks before the school year ended in
Birmingham but when the school year in
Memphis ended
like for two years my mom would send me
to Birmingham to be with my father okay
and so that's where I would go for a
month and then I would go back over to
Mississippi to be with her family for
the most part I traveled in the summer I
never I didn't I don't remember spending
many summers in Memphis gotcha so my mom
would send me to Birmingham with my pops
and it's just me and him but he didn't
trust I was a latchkey kid in Memphis
but my pops didn't trust to leave me at
the house alone because of the
neighborhood
you got to come with me to work so I
would get up and I'm in the first grade
and I would get up at five o'clock in
the [__] morning with my Dad I'm in
the first grade and I'm up at 5 00 a.m
and we would go to Hardee's we would get
a biscuit like I remember that like food
and travel and like the memories parties
was all right the car is where I spent
the most time with my dad and so
we would go to the radio station and he
would do Morning News and I would sit on
the floor and just watch him read copy
for you know
two hours
7 30 hits this woman Francine Palmer
rest in peace she would come and pick me
up and he goes you're gonna be with
Francine today I go okay
then Francine decided
well I don't want to watch him all day
why don't I just drop him off at a
school
I don't think he can do that she talked
to my dad and my dad was like that's a
good idea
he can learn some [__] you can't do that
oh man you got double dipped in school
second my mind I'm coming out of first
grade or something yes literally I would
just get he's at the high school he just
would take you they would take me to
Kingston Elementary School on the North
side the [__] and just dropped me off in
a teacher's and I would just be in that
class for the last three weeks so the
first three weeks of visiting my dad I'm
just in [__] school all day again and
a different dude imagine starting a new
school three with three weeks left in
school nobody wants to [__] play with
in the morning
everybody thought you were a cop oh
every every [__] summer for like it
was two summer straight I got sent to
[__] school for daycare talking
that's crazy now learn some [__] though
Francine don't like kids
watch this [__] all day uh
speaking of cars what are you whipping
around in now I do I sold my car when I
moved to New York in 2015 I had a Kia
Sorento I've only had two cars as an
adult the focus being one of them I had
to focus that my mom bought I wrote that
for 300 000 miles Jesus and then the Kia
when I turned it in 300
000 on a Ford that's all right
in four years four years you put 300 000
miles on it I told you when she bought
me that car it opened up the whole
[__] country bro I drive as far as
Sioux Falls
holy [__] he dropped down to Miami I
took it as far west as El Paso I [__]
yo I [__] rode that car that car if I
could go back and buy it today I would
just [__] if I had a place just to
[__] have it yeah that's a long drive
after you bombed dude yeah yeah okay
yeah driving back from El Paso man [__]
coconuts
yeah you just got nothing but 18 hours I
had one like that in Detroit I had a
long drive bomb in Detroit one time I
went to do open mic in Detroit on a
Monday I called a club and like oh over
Mike's Monday come on up here I show up
a short for sign up and there's like
like two or three people in line it sign
upset five you come back at eight for
Open Mic which I still think is such a
stupid procedure yeah so I come back at
eight
and everybody it's all men
and they're all [__] hoodied and just
[__] in the zone and [__] in
the corner like having a little
freestyle ciphers and [__]
and I go back up to the [__] box
office everyone
if I'm here for open mic where is the
open mic she goes this Open Mic baby
you're in the right place
and I'm wearing a suit this is back when
I used to Performance suits Jesus Christ
open mic
that's garbage I'm like I respect it
but keep in mind I started when I was
19. I was way skinnier than I am so when
I was 19 I looked 14. so the suit added
a little bit of course pay attention to
me okay
I'm 22 I'm in a suit
at this [__] Comedy Club I go yes I'm
here for Open Mic she goes baby
it's open mic rap night oh my God
I go y'all didn't put that on the
website she goes we don't have to
everybody knows not everybody I'm not
from who the [__] does rap night at a
comedy club and I'm like oh y'all just
trying to keep the lights on this is a
Coco shout out to Coco's it's gone now
it's a venue but I've driven I'm here
I'm doing my three minutes oh you're a
bigger if you still want to go up I'll
go yeah
I'm go I know I'm gonna bomb but I drove
so just put she goes she goes well how
about we just put you on last baby I
know yeah that's a good idea
and it's 29 straight right it's 29
people in a row [__] I kill
another [__] yeah you don't know
about the D and the three one three and
then the murder murder
and then I just get out there yeah so
buyback is crazy talking about airplane
food
well it was all college [__] to a room
full of people that could have given a
[__] about it our A's are a pain in the
ass literally that's like the type of
material anyone in a frat what's
happening damn okay buy back that is a
robbery
ah all right yeah let's get into some uh
some kids do some fuse here okay
um any of your family or friends ever
been on the TV show Catfish
negative okay were you a Crystal Light
family growing up
Crystal late Friday 13. no Crystal Light
oh Crystal Light no no we will Kool-Aid
Crystal Light was like white people Coke
because the commercial there's no black
there's no black people in the Crystal
Light commercials back in the day I
can't I don't remember I don't remember
it it had the same Vibe as a Lululemon
commercial whatever
like it just it just didn't register as
a black thing like we take City water
and flavor it and then add sugar
I want this Crystal Light [__]
no no no no okay uh your TSA pre-check
yes
take your shoes off on a plane
if I'm in first class and it's a long
flight okay like if it's a red eye red
eye and I'm laying down there's
something about taking your shoes off
that just helps you go to sleep oh yeah
of course you never like to release a
pressure maybe yeah because if I keep my
shoes on I feel like I'm back to
sleeping in the focus yeah yeah yeah
flashbacks and I'll never go back to
that will you put the seat back on an
airplane let's say you're not in first
class first class I assume no I never
recline really I never required it's not
out of courtesy though why I like how he
said that not because I'm a nice guy no
it's Window Seat no recline because if
you don't recline they can't wake you up
to put your seat back up
strategic 15 so you can start sleeping
earlier in the Border exactly so you get
to sleep on taxi and Landing gotcha
what's your airline you fly you have one
of the years truto uh I'm pretty I'm
pretty regular on Delta yeah
ourselves I I was a continental
I was a well Continental before they
merged with United guy out of the South
I think I think most Community I think
it just boils down to if you live in a
city where this area is yeah yeah like
like my buddy Steve Byrne that's been my
dog for years he is an American Airlines
he's right there yeah and Pittsburgh is
where AAA they got a lot of routes out
of Pittsburgh and Chicago so yeah so it
makes sense whatever's best yeah so I'm
a I'm a Delta guy we bring food on the
plane
like when you order a burger in the
terminal and take it on the plane I'm
very conscious of since I don't want to
be the guy with the like there's a
picture of some this couple that had a
crab boil yeah that's insane
it's a beautiful picture if you did they
have the middle seat with the crab and
the corn and [__]
it's a gorgeous [__] photograph
um not everybody belongs on a plane yeah
that shouldn't happen I took a Chicago
style pizza on the plane Mr Giordano's
he took it he took a deep dish
Giordano's nonetheless I had a I had a
three hour layover at O'Hare and if you
Google there's a there's a Giordano's
pretty close to O'Hare that you can get
in and out of you left to get pizza and
came back you put a pizza through an
x-ray machine called it I called the
order in as we were taxing
to the gate that's called Giordano's
like just a straight just greedy [__]
that I am why did you just eat it then
no I guess what if something happens
with the flight I just want to get back
to the safety of the plane and it's like
a 10-minute debate on whether or not the
sauce on the top counts as a liquid that
I'm bringing in
like they legit had a conversation about
the well I don't know if this is liquid
son I gotta talk to my supervisor so I
brought that
I brought that on the Chicago back to LA
flight Jesus all right did you eat any
on the flight [__] yeah that's a whole
bunch of question right yeah I wasn't
sure I didn't know what you were doing a
slice at the gate okay and then when we
got to the [__] playing okay how to
give the TSA guy a couple of slices too
yeah like for him to play ball
um if you go if you go and get something
on your debit card uh like a CVS or
anything like that will you will you get
cash back
negative I don't I don't use my debit
card for transactions because this is a
hack Fest and yeah smart yeah credit
cards so my shit's protected what are
you what are you working with credit
card wise Amex Capital One I like Amex
for the points shout out to it baby tie
that to the Delta yeah
yeah of course uh okay uh growing up or
now do you keep batteries in the
refrigerator negative my dad did I never
do it my father used to keep 35 mil film
in the fridge too that was the thing as
well to keep film from degrading before
you use it makes sense that the
batteries doesn't I don't know why that
people think that works but film to me
that makes that makes sense I'll tell
you a cheap trick a dark better cool
spot if you need to squeeze a little
extra juice out of a dead battery
piping hot water like water hot enough
for tea uh-huh put the dead batteries in
the water
Let Them Sit five six minutes really
piping hot battery out of the water it's
got extra juice in there really
something that would explode yeah it's
possible
I am missing a couple of things it's
never failed me okay
yeah yeah don't do that yeah like if I'm
in a hotel room in the back I go over to
the coffee maker just run a picture
[Applause]
man I watch MacGyver and Bear Grylls all
right if the housekeeper came in and you
had batteries and boiling hot water
she'd have some questions looks like
you're making meth or something
like [__] Breaking Bad over here dude
God damn someone told me a story one
time of a comedian that was in the room
jacking off when housekeeper came in
he went to apologize
they went out and she ran out the room
of course
I'm sorry I'm trying to apologize and
locked himself outside
[Laughter]
that is such a horrible feeling when you
hear that door lock like once you go oh
I'm [__] [__] it's like the old
police academy where they was it Captain
Bowser when he put all the [__] up
shampoo in his head yeah and it was a he
couldn't see and then he [__] walked
out to the middle of it you know the
[__] that was the first one police ago
we have I think the tape is back there
yeah we have it on we took it off of uh
HBO when I was a kid
um send any venmo requests
requests no
but I'll pay people through like I'll do
spots around New York I get paid in them
sure of course and so then in turn if
I'm working with someone who needs to be
paid in venmo you'll just he'll keep it
in there and send it yeah I just never
take you never take it out never take it
out will you take the customer receipt
at a restaurant if you sign the receipt
will you take the customer copy with you
no and can we stop with the receipt [__]
I'm right there with you what are we
doing uh toast the tablets great
do I like it's on my credit card thing
and then my credit card does a better
job of sorting sure like like like Amex
does like that end of the year this is
what you spend on housing rental cars
whatever whatever Roots all your [__] so
that's enough for me no I've never been
asked to show a receipt I mean in 20
years wait no I take that back I take
the customer receipt and I throw it away
smart because I don't want you to
[__] rewrite another I got jammed
about 500 bucks they took out and
cleared out my bank account really yeah
when I was I was in college I left it
there they took it 500 tip
and then the the business closed that
next day so it was just like the waiter
one last hurray from the waiter I went
back to [__] scream at him and the
balls were boarded up I put the cash
symbol when I write in itself yeah nice
paranoia I like it yeah and then I
blackened out the area to the left of
the cash symbol so you're not adding
you're not remixing
yeah and then I [__] Circle it and
then I get it notarized No More Than
This I go see a judge on Monday
me and the waiter go to the magistrate
I'm leaving I made eight bucks nothing
more nothing less can you open uh a
bottle with a lighter
no I don't smoke so okay I don't know
how to do that but they've taught me
that Wham the bottle on the edge of a
counter trick okay that [__] up the
counter though who taught you that not
counting some
alcoholic in a rush
and alcoholic interrupt some booze back
they had to get to work real quick yeah
because whenever you're like oh let me
find about no bro I Gotta Wait everybody
has their own trick yeah and they wear
it as a badge of honor to show you how
they can do it yeah
um huh are you peeing in the shower you
pee in the shower absolutely
brush your teeth in the shower no
gentlemen okay uh how do you feel about
Hibachi restaurants
um
no no
Korean barbecue I like yeah the classier
Hibachi best I feel like it's like DIY
Hibachi sure sure yeah get your hands
dirty a little bit will you shower in
the morning or at night what's the
routine night shower at night yeah
really I'm nice
early on I dated a woman in college who
believed in getting in the bed clean
clean okay to preserve the cleanliness
of the bed I'm with you makes sense let
me just kind of made sense to me sure
will you dance at a wedding
no really no I don't really know how to
dance then okay
I might I might two-step or something
goofy something easy Electric Slide
Macarena yeah but if you ask me if I'm
out there just running the Dance Floor
oh man freestyling a little bit no uh
okay have you ever saved a Crown Royal
bag
oh yeah
do you have one currently in your
apartment no no I haven't drank Crown in
a while okay once you elevate and stop
drinking bagged liquor what's the go-to
drink for you now you say bag liquor
yeah I thought he said bad lick bag
liquor is a great dirt because really
the the good [__] it's not that Crown
Royal isn't good [__] it's just there's
there's better there's better sure once
you get into better [__] the the
packaging is way more simple and subtle
yeah what are you what are you knocking
around with today if you were going out
after this for a couple of drinks do you
keep do you have a little bar at the
house where you'll have a drink when you
come home after yeah I'm still trying to
build out the little I just got a place
a couple of like last fall so I'm still
trying to figure out all of that but I
got the Ice Cube moles really I got the
circle and that's a square and the
square it's a problem like I got I got
the right cubes because I'm a Manhattan
guy yeah hit me with the Manny's that's
my thing so
pretty much any Top Chef brown liquor I
like that Japanese suntory I do Johnny
Satori time
I still like you got Johnny at the house
yeah
crazy okay where does uh where's Roy
wood uh grocery shopping
there's a couple of like dagostinos
dagostinos is legit classy yeah yeah
Whole Foods man for chicken salad
and there's a couple of things in Whole
Foods that I like but you go to Whole
Food specifically just for the chicken
salad to me they they got a Sonoma
Chicken Salad
is [__] it's chicken it's [__]
pecans grapes celery and then if you
want to get sexy go home shave up some
apples add some apples today a waldorf
salad yeah yeah that's a classic and
what are you putting that on the cracker
crackers I do chicken salad with
crackers sometimes I do a croissant from
zabars what
the [__] okay Kennedy yeah yeah every
now and then you go you go get one of
them Jewish bakeries and get some of
that good soft ass bread
so it's like I'm on like an errand and
it takes me back to my days in high
school where I would go Burger King for
the burger McDonald's for the fries
Chick-fil-A for the milkshake whoa all
on the same day yeah like there's there
was there used to be in Homewood there
used to be a spot
all three like if you if you come down
Green Springs in Birmingham in the 90s
it was a McDonald's and a Burger King
within a block of each other and then
the Chick-fil-A was in enough distance
for you to consume the burger and Fry on
the way to Chick-fil-A to wash it down
to get the trifecta so now if that's
classy or trashy but it's [__] genius
so now I don't like any of the crackers
that's at Whole Foods because I just I
like this guy's real hoity-toity yeah
weird basic ass crackers I don't want
your [__] knockoff Wheat Thin or your
knockoff townhouse I want a nice buttery
[__] basic [__] cracker you're a
rich man yeah Ritz well I'm a club I'm
Keebler Club
townhouse Ritz if you've got nothing
else right yeah Rich is the bottom tier
if you got I don't do vodka if you don't
have any dark I'll try that okay that
sounds like a credit card I'm Keebler
Club yeah
lounge access
they let me in the tree
store for you crackers it's a Food
Emporium you know Walgreens and
dagostinos get your crackers from there
get you to get your chicken salad from
Whole Foods get the bread from zabars
you're very calculated I like it I like
it
you should enjoy food you should not
compromise at any point well I don't
feel like going to no go hey everybody
in the choir get all that good ass bread
and then get you a [__] Tupperware
and keep that [__] stretch it out for a
[__] week and a half do you have a a
regimen like will you go to the grocery
store every Saturday every Sunday or
anything like that or you just kind of
just kind of let it flow no I just kind
of let it flow and usually when I buy
groceries it's just for three or four
days because at some point I'm on the
road
I've tried those meal
mail delivery I've tried them both I've
tried the one where they mail you this
[__] raw and you cook it and then I've
tried the ones where you just reheat
what they cooked in fact New York Chef
just made this yesterday for you and I'm
like I would recommend trying factor
factor meals one's a sponsor so we're
cutting that okay can you just do us a
favorite look at the camera and say you
love factor I like factor
in fact as a matter of fact
that is my favorite meal prep plan and
service mine just got done
um when you eat at the house if you make
dinner do you do it do you order in a
lot you get you get yeah I that's
something I'm guilty of which I'm trying
to be better about okay I'm gonna have
to because you know I'm co-parenting now
so when my son is over I don't want to
just keep ordering right food yeah if
you're by yourself your son's not there
will you eat as will you sit at your
table the kitchen table and eat or will
you sit in front of the TV no I eat at a
table really do you played it I I I or
do you eat out of the container it comes
in
usually out the container just because
of the road comic in there sure sure
because if I'm if I was in a hotel did
he go with an iron or something
yeah I got the batteries in the coffee
pot if it's something like say like like
when I get
I can't even think of the name of the
place Cafe forensic when I get chicken
parm now you're talking my language
there Roy Cafe for instance I like to
like for that to be out get that out the
container okay and really enjoy and
spread your plate set your bread to
whatever uh no I don't eat I don't eat
in the bedroom
I might snack on the couch but like a
full meal nah okay that's some eating a
pizza and watching a movie with somebody
sure but no I like I like to eat at a
table man uh when you watch anything
while you're eating well you put what's
on the iPad watch a show oh yeah
anything goes anything goes wrong but
just at a table bro I'll eat during a
zoom call and I know they start to act
like this is some sort of faux pas and
you shouldn't do it and I'm like
this is me it is yeah this is what
you're buying yeah you want to work with
me or you don't
I want to eat if we came over to your
house right now and you offered us we're
gonna do some water what would you what
how would we get what would the water be
coming it would be a bottle would it be
from the sink uh but the cup right now
picture okay okay and uh in the fridge
it's in the fridge I'm a cold water guy
I don't know how's the filter on that uh
I don't know it's charcoal it's quicker
than the one I had before I had this Pro
Pure or some [__] that was too nice and
it was like a chalk or a granite filter
and it literally would take nine hours
to get a picture yeah yeah how often are
you changing the filter on The Brita
though yeah
cold
[Laughter]
[Music]
it kills half the germs
how about this filter
set a reminder
be a floss every day not every day but
that floss okay uh how do you feel about
the rotisserie chicken
I am a fan
only because the rotisserie chicken
saved me you know sure out on the road
that's six dollars bro six bucks that's
two mils lean meat two yeah yeah I used
to [__] up Boston Market when I first
moved to New York go in there and buy a
whole [__] like a grocery store
rotisserie like
Publix down south public supermarkets
have probably the best rotisserie in the
game Walmart I'm putting second really
I've never had a Walmart that's a bold
statement I in the South though okay
South where they give a [__] about
Flavor yeah like don't just go any
Walmart and go roid said come here I'm
over in Parsippany New Jersey yeah Roy
sent me back to the tires don't do that
that chicken's gonna be trash okay uh
are you a pistachio man negative no
pistachio no I'm a I got a cashew
allergy it's extended to
um pralines and pistachios are in the
same neighborhood so I just I like when
I was like 35 on a flight I ate a cashew
and just out the blue my throat closed
almost asked him to lay on the plane yes
so since that day I'm like okay okay
[__] all y'all sure Irish except for
Snickers that's worth death
like an ice cream Snickers yeah I can
still eat peanuts but cashews pralines
legumes yeah I don't know the difference
I just [__] them all yeah no like even
now when I eat a Snickers that first
bite is just like a little nibble and we
wait to feel if my mouth becomes warm
give it a couple minutes yeah like you
ever drink bleach water no what what's
like the water would be you haven't
accidentally ingested chlorine bleach no
okay when you do your mouth gets really
warm yeah why you're doing real good
here Roy don't blow it now you're
drinking bleach you guys know you guys
know when you're hanging out drinking
chemicals you guys know that right
I'm more of a [__] and span man to be
honest with you your mouth gets super
warm really fast when there's some [__]
that's not supposed to be in your body
it's like a siren I used to work at a
steak delivery places food delivery oh
so he's a medical doctor
oh it's cool I used to be a delivery
driver
no we will bleach the lemonade and the
in a fruit punch fountain oh okay okay I
gotcha bleach water looks like lemonade
gotcha okay put up a whole glass of that
[__] to the Deep Sleep Jesus Christ dude
I didn't know they were cleaning the
[__] he had he didn't cover the spout
the spigot holy when you're cleaning the
[__] [__] you're supposed to cover
the screen on it or something yeah and
my [__] bird didn't I can't [__] you
Bert damn I'll tell you what though the
fountain lemonade is all right
you say you were is it good or is it the
fact that it's is it like are we buying
into the the presentation I think it's
the present yeah Oh you mean those
things yeah those things that that was
like Off the Wall yeah that's what I
drink out of yeah yeah yeah yeah if I
could have one of those in my house
those things are unbelievable that
technology fascinated me as a kid how it
just kept going it was so good yeah
there is there is an element of that to
it uh all right I got a couple more here
uh
uh uh if you had to pick one Fritos
Cheetos or Pringles
Cheetos
flaming hot or straight up not a friend
not a fan of flaming hot okay so
straight up Cheetos is the straight up
Cheetos would be the one okay Pringle
sour cream would be the number two
gentleman's answer no love for Fritos
okay too thick too crunchy yeah then
there's so there's a lot of them and
then they dance yeah like a [__]
Ascent of a pretzel or something I think
just no disrespect to your philly
[__] place sure
um would you walk up to a drive-through
without a car I've tried
[Laughter]
they will not serve you some will some
will I think you have to get a guy who
plays ball a little bit when you get out
of the shower you towel off first of all
how often is that towel getting rotated
[__] you're you're a fresh towel every
every shower no no some people are which
is crazy like you live in a hotel or
something like I'm the dry off towel as
I call it in the black community what's
the other one the the the face towel the
you know your rag your wash your
washcloth sure so you're a washcloth man
washcloth in the shower yes or a loofah
or some scrubbing abrasive soap
something exfolio gotcha something I
like that so sorry you use uh uh a body
wash or a bar soap what do you what are
you not going around for a bar soap okay
I don't know some weird [__] from
lassitana like some [__] French [__]
I don't even know what happened give
that a Google I can't do the grocery
store sub they should be drying you out
and they'll [__] you up for sure be all
scared of the chemicals of that [__]
um washcloth I'll probably rotate every
three days the dry out the dry off claw
the dry off towel probably every four
days that's real that's good that's
right just trying off with it it's like
okay but the washcloth is doing a lot of
work it's picking up the dirt you gotta
rotate that one now where does the towel
go when you're done drying off does it
go over your your door in your bedroom
does it go over the shower curtain why
I've never understood that I've never
understood the dry off towel making it
out of the bathroom really I bring my
clothes into the shower wait hold on
draw your house yeah I just used to
shower my truck stops and [__] though
shout out to the Flying J so you gotta
be on his [__] toes so like you dry
off then you put that towel on a towel
rack in the bathroom then you put on
your [__] clothes in the
bathroom and then you go back out into
the world full clothes
no but at least draws okay I'm dry and
at least presentable
so this child there's no need for this
top but I also don't [__] with robes
either because I don't I don't make
moves naked
[Laughter]
make moves that's the funniest thing
I make moves naked exclusively I don't
unders I just I'm not a rogue person
wait hold on don't just somebody I have
this you go in the shower you shower yes
you dry off in the shower do you open
the door to the bathroom to get that
fresh air in they're really dry yeah
yeah yeah
okay you push you push the shower
curtain back you dry off because you're
dripping so let the drip drip in the tub
then step out you've done upper body now
you lay that same tile down feet ankles
now you put that thing up on the rack
put your drawers on now you're ready to
leave the bathroom okay but I know
people who just tie the tile around
their waist and then they do all of the
lotion and hair and post shower routine
in the bedroom I've never done that but
then I've also always had to share
bathroom with your mom and then when you
travel like when I was in Mississippi
with all of my cousins you can't come
out and do [__] because it's a house
full of [__] in a hotel when
you're by yourself where you walk around
the hotel room naked no really you don't
make moves naked huh get clothes on
immediately really yeah something could
happen
something is that a joining door opens
you gotta be [__] on yourself the
same reason I don't [__] with flip-flops
other than at the pool what in case
you're gonna fight yeah oh you need to
run somebody might shoot like I have
[__] trauma like I've been around
enough weird [__] in my brain she could
jump off I need [__] clothes to
there's a shoe
I don't remember the brand but there is
a closed-toe neoprene looks like one of
them Kanye shoes or whatever but it's
like
it's rubberized and you can wear it in
the ocean oh yeah whatever it's called
it goes around the it fully encloses
your foot yeah I've been fantasizing
about a pair of those
they were big in the 90s even if they
get to shooting in the ocean I can just
be out [__] run you should put on
flippers and go the other way just go
further out in the water just get out as
quick as possible baby oh man I'm
staying with getting dressed
socks go on before your pants
or pants and socks that's a good
question
usually socks then pants like if it's
jogging pants something with a tight
cuff or elastic cuff that's going to
grip it's easier for me to bring the
pants up over the sock okay so I'm not
shoving sock under the elastic and all
of that stuff all right uh yeah socks
first okay how do you feel about the
deviled egg love the devil today I
prefer it with the relish chopped up
inside it okay paprika yes a little bit
of that that that Cube salt whatever
those big salt sea salt sea salt is it
kosher salt yeah kosher salt like it's
the big pieces of salt I like that on
that too you have a go-to cereal
I will always have a soft spot for Fruit
Loops okay
man amen every blue moon and it's not
like at The Daily Show they let the
interns buy the cereal and so there's
like here's the nine you must buy and
then here's five boxes of just whatever
whatever's clever yeah they let they let
the kids kind of just to help mix it up
and variety and every now and then
they'll grab a Cinnamon Toast Crunch and
I'll [__] it up yeah but I don't buy
cereal for the house like it just okay
those two candy like I like like as a 44
year old man I feel like oatmeal with
walnuts is what I'm supposed to be
eating sure like that's the image I want
my son to have of me he can't be digging
for the prize at the bottom of Frosted
Flakes in front of your kids yeah in
front of your kid oh son we're just
gonna get this follow the nose it's like
no
oh my [__] your daddy eats this
boring [__] now stare at me trying to
stay alive look at your daddy trying to
live longer to [__] be with you who's
uh who's cutting the hair
um I got a barber here
um you go there they come to you for the
most part I go to his shop but he also
cuts hair at The Daily Show so there you
go so because he's you know because he's
in the hair and makeup Union sometimes
he's down at the show to cut a guest or
cut somebody in the building so I can
kind of sneak yeah like that was the
biggest thing when Trevor left [__] I
lost my goddamn weekly haircut uh why he
got it cut every week yeah cause the
barber will come down to cut Trevor's
man so I just uh when you're done with
traveling cleaned me up a little bit
yeah I was thinking about this the other
day when you get your hair cut on set do
you tip on set no
there is not a penny that comes out of
your pocket if you if I get my some of
the best haircuts I've ever gotten were
for TV Productions and they are paid
crazy yeah they're they're you make a
solid living they're not burning and
turning they're not trying to get you
out of the chair you're making way more
than you would if you do it on a regular
enough basis as a union Barber on set
you can make close to what you would
have been making in a shop if you had a
chair and a regular flow of customers
but of course then something like the
writer strike happened the production so
it's like
there's a there's a gift there's a
balance yeah when high top when it's
good it's good it's [__] great okay
that's all right I got one more and then
I'm and then I'm clear okay uh
you go to a steakhouse how do you get
your steak cooked
steaks are medium Ribeyes only Cowboy
preferred
um pretty good
um
I know some people get a porterhouse or
something like if I'm on a date with
someone and she wants a different cut
I'll defer to her cut of meat gentlemen
okay gentlemen but if you're getting a
porterhouse for two yeah and you gotta
share it you'll give it to her but I
hope and pray that she wants it medium
I've dated a couple of medium rares and
it was it was difficult would you rather
go higher or lower lower
you mean you'd rather you'd rather it
medium rare than medium well medium well
can be [__] up it's with medium rare I
can hope and pray that there's some
shorts yeah and I can just get the Outer
Perimeter
yeah and on a date or with friends are
you a single appetizer guy or are you
sharing everything let's share let's
figure out something for everybody to
share but there's always one appetizer I
really want yeah me too baby and I'll
try and order two of those to make sure
I get my points yeah because I'm like
the guy like like I hate [__] group
nachos
wait why
nachos is one of the most man I get you
so much the the lack of equity across
you know let's talk about Equity glaze
diversity and inclusive top one percent
of chips have all the good topics and
some [__] gets the chip and doesn't
have the decency to get that chip and a
dry chip and then bounce it balance it
and make your nacho sandwich so you get
even to so you might get the chip with
all the [__] chicken and the cheese
and then I'm stuck with a sour cream and
two Olive [__] [__]
man and they go let's get nachos for the
table it's like let's just all not be
happy yeah there's no way you're doing
them now where they they span them out
they span them out like they put them on
cookie sheets so everything gets an
equal distribution is that like in a
Mexican restaurant that sounds like a
Mexican I don't know I saw it online to
be honest because I've seen Mexican
restaurants that take the Nacho
[__] more serious because they other
baked the cheese the nacho them in the
oven it's not that
[Music]
okay see that I would I would prefer
yeah okay no give me give me something
then okay I just got uh two more
um Mayo Hellman's or Miracle Whip the
Hellman's regular Mayo Miracle Whip is a
little [__] too sweet now you want
something to blow your goddamn mind get
that Japanese Mayo I know exactly what
you're talking about oh my God it's
called like Weepies or I don't know what
it's called it seemed like a little
thing my girl gets it but it's halfway
between Miracle Whip and American yeah
it's just the perfect tang and sweet
okay so you put that [__] on a [__]
hot dog bro
see this is why I'm on the fence with
him he's classy and then trashy what no
hot dogs you want the expense hot dogs
of course you but they're not you want
the expensive fancy Mayo but yeah you
put it on a hot dog absolutely yeah he's
the duality of man oh that's right no
Mayon hot dog [__] Americans
I'm in I love it I like what you're
putting down not on a brat you go
mustard on a brat that meets two [__]
salty to disrespect with mayo what else
is going on your hot dog let's clear
this up
um let's get some after this now if you
want you want to know the real bougie
please [__]
I go bun open preferably Hawaiian roll
gentlemen Top Cut don't really [__] with
the side cut whoa
prefer the top cut it's because the side
you open up in the hinge jacket comes
loose and now you got your own coming up
it's very suspect on the side cut hot
dog bun Top Cut you know what you're
getting you crack it open I'll go Mayo I
go a passive yellow mustard I'll go a
passive relish then the dog on top of
the toppings whoa
items on to encase and enclose the
toppings underneath to keep all this
[__] slippage and it's less messy
doing all this [__] it's not wrong he
turned therapings into bottoms
steady betting flavors now if you really
want to go next level adding the flavors
if you really want to go next level put
the hot dog in give it a Twist bring
some of that top sauce and residue from
the bottom up to the top layer and now
you're getting the top your palette is
getting a little bit of flavor on both
sides on every bite that way when you
bite the hot dog you're not just getting
toppings in one side of your mouth and
meat on the other side of your mouth you
get an even balance the problem is you
have to do you should be running for
office I know what's going on at least
like you know commander-inchiva hot dogs
or something the problem though is that
more often not when you're eating hot
dogs it's with a group of people and you
know [__] are watching you and
judging you and how you're prepared like
just just recently I was at a barbecue
and they had the baked beans going so
sometimes I go with the baked beans on
top of the dog no sauce you're an
American can I get it baked beans only
yeah
try to do my baked bean bed and then
like I'm going through my routine and
they're like what the [__] are you doing
just eat that because I'm like no more
Garcia para and have you ever seen
videos like this is baseball player that
would go through the guy from the Red
Sox yeah yeah okay there's video of it
it's a legend where Garcia power after
it is pre-pitch clock
after every pitch he would go through
the same yeah routine of straightening
his uniform read velcro in the glove
twisting the back fixing it like he
would go through all his [__] and then
get back in there but he just had
Neurosis that's how I am with preparing
a hot dog if I really want it the way I
want sure so but you should have you've
earned you deserve Japanese Mayo is the
[__] [__] damn the best sandwich I've
ever had the best piece of seafood I've
ever had was a Burger King BK and then
he does this
this is Tokyo oh I'm out I'm done I
can't deal with this guy is the tartar
sauce was based the base of the tartar
was Japanese Mayo
tartar sauce with Japanese Mayo as a
base over a fish sandwich that doesn't
have half the chemicals that they put in
the wands in America fast food is fresh
as [__] overseas yeah damn this guy is
good top three fish sandwich I've ever
had huh Burger King in Tokyo see he's
pure 50 50 down the line
burger I ate them for three days I was
in Tokyo and I [__] ate Burger King
three days in a row because it was good
you're in Tokyo you're gonna try oh [__]
all that other [__] they add some
octopus inside a hush puppy that was
good what are we doing he's perfectly 50
trash and 50 the classiest guy I've ever
met in my life
hush puppy yeah you love a hush puppy
and then everybody loves a [__]
decent piece of calamari octopus ain't
[__] but [__] meaty [__] calamari
yeah put that [__] in a hush puppy that
[__] was amazing he's drinking bleach
he's got Japanese Mayo I don't know
what's happening
man ladies and gentlemen Mr Roy wood man
what's your verdict Kip I I honestly
I've called a 50 50 one other time I
think but this is the most down the line
both sides of the fence 50 50. he's the
epitome of I mean he's doing credit card
schemes in like ninth grade or whatever
and he's got Japanese mayonnaise that's
he's a well-cultured man I'm saying 50
50. I gotta say this
um I I understand the 50 50 but his
garbage Tendencies are extremely
methodical yes so I'm gonna say all
class
it's the first weird split Toby you want
to do the tie breaker what are you
thinking first time ever
it's like 60 40 class I think okay I'll
give you that I'll give you that I'll
meet you there 64. take food on the
plane but it's a deep dish pizza yes
every movie makes he then confuses me
with the next movie you think I'm gonna
take a [__] Charlie's Philly
cheesesteak
extra onions no dude I try to Google his
soap and I had to put in my password for
the Illuminati
it's verbena soap from L'Occitane that's
what it is yes it sounds like a French
restaurant
I'll do it a lot I'll do uh the nachos
and the soap and lots of time ladies and
gentlemen Mr Roy wood he is on tour
right now he is one of the funniest guys
you have to go and see him this was fun
thank you buddy yeah this is great buddy
we love you we've been so excited to
have you thank you so much for coming in
anything else you want the folks out
there to know oh that's it man just come
out and see me live Virginia Beach you
said next yeah Virginia Beach Hartford
we playing from Sacramento to Hartford
down to Miami man so awesome we're
getting all the time zones in if you
don't see your city no it's getting at
it because it's a strike I ain't got
[__] to do that
ladies and gentlemen for Roy wood thank
you what do you got for him we're also
all over the road we're announcing the
next leg of our tour for the fall and
the winter so get those tickets because
they are moving quick we appreciate it
we love you gang we love you and we'll
see you next week peace